تسببت الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا في عصابه
الاقتصاد الاوكراني بشلل لم يسبق له مثيل
في تاريخ البلاد فقد اعلن المستشار
الاقتصادي للرئيس الاوكراني ان كلفه هذه
الحرب ادت الى خساره الاقتصاد الاوكراني
نحو التريليون دولار وتدمير نحو 30% من
اقتصاد اوكرانيا
اكثر من ذلك صرعته الميزانيه الاوكرانيه
يرتفع باكثر من خمسه مليارات دولار شهريا
وكشفت وكاله بلومبرج تهاوي الناتج المحلي
الاجماليه الاوكراني باكثر من ثلاثين في
العام الماضي وهو اكبر تراجع يشهد اقتصاد
تلك الدوله منذ ان استقلت قبل ثلاثه عقود
وبلغ عجز الميزانيه في العام الماضي ما
يعادل
27% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي الاوكراني
كما قفز معدل التضخم في البلاد الى 20%
وقد يتجاوز حاجز 30% هذا العام
وكان قطاع السلع الزراعيه من اكبر
المتضررين على هذا الصعيد حيث ارتفعت
اسعار الخضروات بنسبه 85% مع تحول منطقه
خرسون وهي اكبر منتج للخضروات في البلاد
الى ساحه لقتال عنيف معروس
وانخفض محصول القمح من 32 مليون ونصف
مليون طن عام 2021 الى 26 مليون و600 الف
طن العام الماضي وقد ذهب ربع هذا الانتاج
الى روسيا
قيمه العمله المحليه هوت بنسبه 25% اما
معدل البطاله فقفز الى 40% في المقابل
بلغت خسائر البنيه التحتيه التي تشمل
الطرق والجسور والمنازل والمدارس
والمستشفيات
والاراضي الصالحه للزراعه
127 مليار دولار اكثر من ذلك فانه من
المتوقع ان تقفز نسبه من يعانون من الفقر
المتقع في البلاد لتصل تسعه عشر وثمانيه
عشر في المئه هذا العام بعد ان كانت واحدا
وثمانيه اعشار في المئه قبيل الحرب
هذا الامر دفع اورسولا فوندير لاين رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه الى ان تعلن انه من
غير المعقول الا تدفع روسيا تكاليف اعاده
اعمار اوكرانيا